みなさんこんにちは脳の学校代表の加藤です
今日は
皆さんがどうやって来頃
生きていったらいいか
生きるためには脳使わなければいけません
今世の中に必要なのは脳の取説だと私は思っています
世界の共通言語ってなんだと思いますか
皆さんは英語だと言うでしょう私はブレーン no だと思いますね
だからこそ脳の取説を知ってその先に世界平和も
人類の
発展も地球の環境の整備もあるんだとそう考えています
がしかしかながらそんな大風呂敷を広げても私たちは
3人も世の中を変えることができず
何を変えるべきか
私はまず皆さんは一人一人
自分自身を変えるチャレンジをしてみたら彼がと思います
そのためにはどうしたらいいか
皆さんの脳を変えることです
私の脳
最初に変えてくれた
人は
母親です
母のささやき
今から50年以上前に
現在78歳の母親は私に支えきました
頭は使えば使うほどよくなるからって
ずっとささやきます今でも電話せると操作でただきます
消すて認知症ではありません
この母親はなぜ囁いたか
まあ出来の悪い息子だったんですね小学校2年生の時
通知表に家さんですね
国語2
今本をいっぱい書いてるのに国語に夜釣り国語の成績と本の数は関係ない
そんな母親がずっと囁いて50年後に
お母さん
どうしたら頭が使えたらいいのどうやって使ったらいいの
頭が使えないから僕は頭が悪いんだってずっとそう思ってきました
らしかしながら私は母親に言い返すことはありませんでした
ひたすら
50年以上その
事実を
どうやって使ったらいいか求めてきましたそして今皆さんの前で私は頭の使い方を話し
ているんです
オンリーワンの今まで私が受けてきた教育の医学部も行きました
予備校も行きました
最高の教育は母親の
笹駅たった一言頭は使えば使うほどよくなるからこれ
これを超える教育法はありませんでしたね
ですから皆さんにもこのメッセージを送りたいと思います
それを共有したいと思います
第2番目もう一つは自然ですね
皆さんは便利効率がいい
それによって時間を得た
効率が良くなって時間を得て何に使いますか
衰えたのものは何だと思いますか皆さんの筋肉に来たいですよ
時間を得て衰えた肉体は何を
引き起こすんですか脳の衰えです
自然と関わることがまず2番目の脳の教科書です
私のほうは今20万部4年前に出したのが売れているそうです
実感はありません
がしかしながら今これが世の中に必要なのは明白です
科学者の私はそれがわかっていましたがしかしながら世の中がそれよ
に反応するかどうかは
社会の趨勢や環境によるんですしかしながら科学者はその1滴の
インスピレーションを世の中に落としていく必要がある
そう考えています誰も褒めません
誰も称賛してくれませんがしかしながら私たちは
向かうべき道に向かうべきなんだとそう
思いますね
そして私はとにかく頭が使えないから
小学校2年生の時に着物を着て母親が
父兄会に行ってきたんですね帰ってきたら青ざめてるんですね
その光景ありありと覚えています
なんて言われたかお宅の息子さんは体もでかいし
条学校2年生の教室の窓から海ばっかり見てるし
知恵遅れじゃないか
青ざめてですねじゃあオファーちゃんがいや将来どうなるかわからないから大切に
育てようと覚えてるんですね
なぜ私が海をばっかり見ていたからそれは私の
祖父が海で漁してたんですね
海にた海が大好きだから
祖父の船を探して
教室小学校の教室の2階の窓から探していたわけですがしかしそれはいいわけです
国語の本も読めませんでした家にも1冊も本がありません
父も母も小学校しか出てませんその私が医学部に出て皆さんに
能の話をする奇跡ではありません
脳を
改造する自分自身で鍛えるそして伸ばすそれによって私たちは進化することができます
私がそれで気づいたのは
このまず体を鍛えれば何とか母は喜ばせるんじゃ
でできるんじゃないかと思ったんですねそれでこれ見ての通り
これからこういうふうになりました
この時中学3年生です中学3年生の時私は垂直ジャンプ110センチぐらいありました
驚異110センチ後藤んと死亡ありません
あの海でずっと筋肉すべての筋肉を鍛えれば万能の選手になれると思ったんですね
運動やりすぎて体もいただけました
しかしそのおかげでですね
体を動かす限界
脳は体を鍛えても
すべてを鍛えられることができないんだって言うなんとなくわかったんですね
それで小学校3年生から
なんでもいいからその新潟県中心なんですねそれで新潟県のスポーツと1位になって親
を喜ばせようと思って5年計画
あれは6年契約だったんですね中学3年生の8月7日か6日に県大会があってそこで
本当に優勝するんですけどその前に
一人でグラウンドで練習した時に汗が垂れタラタラだったりているときに脳だって
気づいたんですね
なぜか
自分の体を動かしているのはこの脳ミソなんだって言う
皆さん今 no だって何でもわかりますよ
でも40年前の能なんて髪きれいにも書かれていない新聞にも出てない
今 no 溢れていますよ間違った脳が
oh no なんて冗談でも言えない
そこで
医学部に入りました
医学部に行くと何天才的な紙みたいな
偉そうな教授が現れて
加藤よ脳はこうならいなさいと教えてくれるばっかりと思っていた
だから僕は中学でスポーツを優勝しても推薦ってどこでも行けると言われても一切断っ
て無視して医学部にいた映画9分我慢して6年間
座ってました皆さんのようにいつか髪が現れると思って
現れなかった
あっというまです自分の生主を返せと思った
本当に
それで一番成績の悪い小児科医になりました
これが良かった
小児科医になって半年で失敗したなと思いました
忙しすぎる
しかしながら当時
医学の中で mri が使われ始めました
でこれで患者さんを見ながら脳を見て一緒に付けあわせていましたそうしたら徐々に
わかってきました
医学部には脳が成長する法則なんて教える理由も
原則も
モチベーションもないんだとなぜかというと病院は病気を治すとこの病気を研究するん
です
僕が求めていたのは健康な脳を育てることだったんだと
初めて
気づいたんですね
それで私はこの脳が成長する方走行を求めてきました今は脳の個性を診断する技術を
持ちました
一人一人
どんな構成可能見ただけでその人がどういう特徴ありどういう生活をしているどういう
考え方をするかわかります
それは僕があまり今も
うまく本を読めない代償で小さい時から目を見て
光景を見て
目で情報収集して解析しての生きてきたことに非常に関係していると思いますね
このように私たちは経験して体験しすることによっていろんな個性が生まれて自分の脳
が
方土作られるんです1万人以上のを見てきて一人も同じ人がいない
双子でもいないなぜか
それは私たちの環境や経験がすべてノーに移し替えられて本当は no という臓器
っていうのは私たちの個性を表す
ためにそれを保持してさらに進化するための臓器だったんです決して単純に頭から指令
を送る役割じゃなかっただから人類は脳の役割再発見してなかったんですね
そこで
私考えました
いや子供の脳は1キロなんですよ
皆さんの脳はそれにプラスステーキ1枚ですよ
350g の中に大人のことを大人と子供の差がどこに存在しているか考えたんですね
このヒントがひょっとしたら
人間の能力をつくっているさではないか
違いじゃないかと思ったんですねすぐには答えてませんよ
ここから結構苦しんだ
これですね
これは私が発明した画像方ですね枝振り画像と言います生まれたばっかり
それから行動もさんこれは皆さんの脳ですみてください脳のネットワークが映像化され
ますそして黒くなっていきますねこれは脳の無いのネットワークで皆さんが今使って
いるところが黒く写るんですそうするとみてください
右と左この太さが違うじゃないですか
ここも違う右と左皆さんの
鼻から右と左左右対称に見えるけれども脳の中はもっと非対称なんです
なぜか最初ツルツルだったのに枝ができていくわけだから
この成長の減速が違うということです
なぜこうなったか経験が違うんですね経験したところが太くなっていくんですよ
経験していたいないところは苦手であり不得意であるなんですね
要するに未熟なわけですよそうすると能力って一体何かということです
能力というのは皆さんの経験そのものによって
伸ばした脳の番地なんですみてください全部均等じゃないということは場所ごとに伸び
ていくんですね
こういう脳が成長する原則がわかれば私たちは自分で自分の脳も鍛えられ
伸ばすことができます
大風呂敷を広げるよりもまず自分を改革しましょうよ
みなさんは自分の脳見た事がありますか
素晴らしい体験をしたらその前後でのみたらどうですか
今の技術は1カ月前後で脳が変わっているのを検出できます
もちろんそんなことを館カーの鑑定できる医者はほとんどいません私以外は今のところ
そうじゃない人いるって言っててあげて欲しいんだけど誰も出てこない
それではいけないんですけれども
要するに
脳というのは経験して形を変えて成長する臓器だったんです
進退の中から未熟から始まりそれでもみかんな臓器というのは脳だけなんです
それそのものが脳の役割だったんですねそれを気づかせてくれた
立った母親の頭は使えば使うほどよくなるからというメッセージによって
そこでよく考えてみると
脳っていうのはこんな広いいろんな役割はがある細胞の種類も50種類以上もっと
いっぱいあります
第の皮質だけで50種類以上あるわけだから大雑把に分けて脳の働きというのは前頭八
の思考型の御鉢
考えますね怒り笑感情系脳番地
こうやっておしゃべ
にね伝達系の番地体を鍛える運動系の番地
記憶するそれから聞く見る
物事をいろいろ理解運動する
こういったものの集まりによって脳が構成されてるんですよ
だから私が中学までに必死になって全ての筋肉を鍛えて万能な人間になると願っても
運動系脳番地に関連するものだけを抜けたんですね
そこで高校に入った座っているのがつらかった
とにかくまともに本をやったことがないからでも医学部に行くために
読めない本も一生懸命選んだつらかったねー
それはこの側頭葉
要するに知識がなかった本を読まないと世の中の社会この社会は言語言語を集めて
いろんな新しい言語を生み出して交流しているのでその言語環境に能力が依存するん
ですよだから僕みたいに映像が読めたり綺麗な映画作れたりというのは
評価
することができないそれが能力のあの一番のその
見つけることができない能力の違いですねだから言語能力が卓越してきている人だけが
非常に社会で目立つ
これは脳の番地を意識しないからです
だから脳の番地というのは能力革命につながることなんです
私が革命するんじゃないですよ脳そのものがそういう存在だったということをお伝えし
たいだけです
例えばこの27歳の女性すごく頭いいですよ
言語年後能力卓越ですがしかし自分の目で見て行動するということが足らなかった
なのでないものに気づく発見するという能力まだなかったんです
ん
あなたはこのままでいいって言ったら私やって言うから
育つ育てる方法脳が育てる方法教えました2年後
女性なのに頭の中にひがを開いてきた
白いところを黒くなっています
要するにノーというのはこういうふうに変わるんです
脳が変わって何が得か世界観が違う
この脳で同じことを見るこの脳で同じことを見る
全く違う脳が変わったら自分自身が変わってるんですよだから感じ方もアイディアも
変わって当たり前なんです
私が色々な人を見てきて脳を伸ばすことで
アンハッピー
嫌な人はひとりもいません人間が耐えられないのは目を開けて頭が働かないで空白な
状態が辛い
子どもは学校でつまらない教師の話を聞いてもじもじと動き始める
それは教師の
スピーチの教え方が下手くそだからですなぜか
子供ののを動かすことができない
もちろん子供にも原因はありますよ
さて
まとめるとこの5つの脳番地の強化法
これは
単に
以上重要なことだけを書きます頭は使えば使うほどよくなるからその通りなんですこの
使い方が問題な使い方が脳番地の使い方なんですよ
私の母は偉かった
でも no なんて言えでそんな話したこともない
自然は脳の教科書すべての筋肉を鍛える
皆さんはこれ諦めてはいけません使ってない筋肉いっぱいある
筋肉に連動して脳の使い方が違う
頭が働かないアイデアがない人はぜひ使ってない
体の筋肉使ってください
歯磨きを反対の手でをやるのもいい私は4歳の時に左利きから右利きに変えるために
習字書道に行きましたそれによって右手を使う左手を使うそういったことがああ
いつも考えて行動するようになります
だからこそそれが今脳番地トレーニングを考える時に非常に役に立ちました
no バーチトレーニングは書籍にも書いてあるし
いろんなことを考えればいろんなことが湧いています
一番大事なのは皆さん自身が自分で自分の脳バッジトレーニングに目覚めることだと
思います
それそのものが自分を変えることが
と形を変えて世界を変えてそれが脳の共通言語脳のトリセツ
今必要なことこれが世界
を求めることが大事なことは脳の取説なんです
だから私は脳の成長の仕方を解くそれが今日この場に立った理由ですご清聴ありがとう
ございました